I know tens of thousands of people I
know thousands of people extremely well
I know hundreds of people deeply well
there is no correlation between how much
money someone makes and their level of
happiness I have friends who make
$47,000 a year and are the happiest
people I know their work-life balance is
on point they're part of two soccer
teams they play video games they watch
every show they want they take two
vacations that they scrap together and
they're freaking happy as hell and I
know tons of people who I grew up with
in the Silicon Valley boom who have
hundreds of millions of dollars in their
bank account and are is miserable and is
lonely and is broken as you'll ever see
so I implore all of you to please
reverse engineer and figure out who you
are and figure out what level of
monetizing and stuff you need and what
level of creativity need I promise you
one thing one thing I will catch you
very off guard
I should be way more rich I leave money
on the table every day
I've left ungodly amounts of money on
the table
I spend tons of times spending sending
DMS and engaging with people meeting
people randomly and not cashing in I
actually believe the statement I'm about
to make I think that I love the journey
and the game of entrepreneurship so much
that I have subconsciously sabotage my
financial upside to make sure I can play
this a little longer because I fear if
the numbers keep getting too big
eventually it will take the fun out of
it when you are lucky enough like I am
to actually do something that you love
so much do something that puts pressure
against the one thing you care about
besides it which is the time I spend
with my family I didn't waste my whole
life and being this and doing this is
the only thing that cuts into that I
couldn't breathe if I wasn't an
entrepreneur I didn't breathe when I
wasn't an entrepreneur that's the reason
I got D's and F's in school because I
just couldn't be me and I'm not capable
of that and so I think being here
excites me because I think coming to not
LA San Francisco New York London is
always more fun from
it always feels a little more practical
it always feels like there's a little
bit more chips on the shoulder which is
what I have but I want to remind
everybody just because he didn't grow up
with a trust fund just because you don't
live in Silicon Valley the market
doesn't care if you're good enough you
will win
[Music]